we bombard our brains with so much
dopamine that our brains have to
compensate by way down regulating our
own dopamine production and transmission
then we end up in this chronic dopamine
deficit state where nothing else is
enjoyable we're only focused on our drug
of choice we need to keep using not to
feel good but just to restore a level
balance and feel normal and when we're
not using our drug we're experiencing
the universal symptoms of withdrawal
from any addictive substance which are
anxiety irritability insomnia depression
and craving
it's like one of those buzzwords at the
moment i've seen dopamine fasting and
dopamine detoxes thrown around youtube a
lot
and we're talking about imbalances in
the brain is it chemical is it
environmental
what's your favorite framework for
explaining what dopamine is and how it
affects us
well my framework for communicating the
role that dopamine has in our brain
it really has to do with the fact that
pleasure and pain are processed in the
same part of the brain
it's a part of the brain called the
reward pathway
and
pleasure and pain effectively work like
opposite sides of a balance
so when we do something pleasurable that
balance tips to the side of pleasure and
we get a little release of dopamine in
our brain's reward pathway which is
reinforcing and feels good but one of
the overarching rules governing this
balance is that it wants to remain level
it doesn't want to be tipped for very
long to the side of pleasure or pain
and the brain will work very hard to
restore a level balance or what's called
homeostasis
but importantly
the way that the brain
brings that balance back to a level
resting state is first by tipping it an
equal and opposite amount to the side of
pain
and that's where when our brain down
regulates our own dopamine production
and our own dopamine transmission not
just back to baseline levels but
actually below baseline levels to this
dopamine deficit state
now if we wait long enough you know
that's that feeling of wanting another
piece of chocolate just one more video
game another drink if we wait that
passes and our balance is restored
but if we continue to
repeatedly expose ourselves to highly
reinforcing drugs and behaviors
then over time that initial stimulus
gets shorter and weaker but that after
response gets stronger and longer
which is why typically we need more of a
drug or more potent forms over time to
get the same effect
and furthermore what can end up
happening is our our balances can kind
of get stuck
on the pain side where we end up i like
to think of it as these neural
adaptation gremlins hopping on the pain
side of our balance kind of camping out
there
if we bombard our brains with so much
dopamine that our brains have to
compensate by way down regulating our
own dopamine production and transmission
then we end up in this chronic dopamine
deficit state where nothing else is
enjoyable we're only focused on our drug
of choice we need to keep using not to
feel good but just to restore a level
balance and feel normal and when we're
not using our drug we're experiencing
the universal symptoms of withdrawal
from any addictive substance which are
anxiety irritability insomnia depression
and craving
what is the sensation of dopamine how
would you describe what it feels like
for someone to have it and not have
it well dopamine fluctuates around this
tonic baseline so we're always releasing
dopamine at sort of a constant steady
rate and it's really the way it
fluctuates up and down below this
baseline level that affects the way we
feel
typically when it rises above baseline
levels and we have more dopamine in our
reward pathway we feel good we can feel
really really good we can feel even
euphoric or sometimes it's just a sense
of calm well-being or a sense of not
being anxious
so it's all of those things wrapped into
one
whereas when dopamine goes below
baseline again we feel restless we feel
anxious
we feel like something's missing in our
life
and we have a lot of incentive and
motivation to use that drug again in
order to
not just recreate that good feeling but
also just bring us back to a normal
homeostasis why do we have a dopamine
balance is it
adaptive well it has been adapted for
most of human existence if you think
about it our brains were evolved to
approach pleasure and avoid pain
and that's been conserved over millions
of years of evolution as we've lived in
a world of scarcity and ever-present
danger
but the problem is that now we no longer
live in that world we live in this world
of overwhelming abundance and we're very
insulated from all kinds of painful
experiences such that what was once
adaptive is no longer so
i think that we really need to rethink
the way that we live in this highly
dopamine overloaded world
why is it
so if that's the case if it's the case
that we feel calm sometimes at a
moderate increase of dopamine and we
feel comfortable
does that not mean that trying to feel
calm and comfortable all of the time is
inherently a wasted effort because
you're going to go back to baseline
eventually
it is that something that we can't chase
we can't be in that sort of calm
comfortable situation all the time
yeah i mean you've really intuited what
is essentially the bottom line
of the way that pleasure and pain are
processed in our brain that really any
kind of for any kind of reward seeking
there is a cost and that cost is the
come down and the pain
and that the harder we try to be in that
place of comfort and reward
the larger the price that will pay the
greater the dopamine deficit state such
that ultimately there is futility
um in seeking out reward for its own
sake is there a different dopamine set
point for each person is that or
tolerance or degrees and dopa
the same level balance but it's probably
not true
there are probably people who you know
metaphorically
start off with a balance that's tilted
slightly to the side of pain that could
be because of people who live with
chronic pain that could be people with
depression
there are studies showing that
people with depression
probably have lower baseline
dopamine levels or might be less
sensitive
to
typical rewards and might need more of
certain types of rewards in order to get
their dopamine to rise up above baseline
levels all of which potentially makes
those people more vulnerable to the
problem of addiction as they seek out
rewards to just feel normal not
necessarily you know feel good
why is it that people that are in
chronic pain don't find pleasure
superbly easily then if you're saying
that it's one side of the same seesaw
the people that are in chronic pain
should be able to feel amazing off just
a tiny little glimpse of something
that's nice is that not the way it works
no remember one of the overarching rules
governing this balance is that it wants
to preserve homeostasis so it wants to
go back to whatever that baseline is and
it will work very hard to do that i mean
there are you know evolutionary just so
stories for why that is but essentially
a person with chronic pain
who starts out in pain their physiologic
system will want to return to that
baseline so for example if they take an
opioid to try to get out of pain that
will initially work but over time
they'll need more and more of that
opioid to get the same effect
and ultimately the initial response to
the opioid will get weaker and shorter
in duration and the after effect and
this is really probably the most
fascinating
aspect of this pleasure pain balance is
that after effect gets stronger and
longer
so with repeated exposure to the same or
similar pleasure stimulus we end up in a
deeper dopamine deficit state it lasts
longer it goes further down
so a person with chronic pain has to
experience that pain below even beyond
their baseline pain before returning to
their baseline pain so in other words
there's no free lunch what goes up must
come down and if you start out in
chronic pain
you're also subject to the same problems
of tolerance needing more and more to
get the same effect and the dependence
and withdrawal which are essentially
this dopamine deficit state it's a
vicious asymmetry the fact that you need
more and more to gain less and less
pleasure
but the more and more will incur an even
larger power law return of depression
and feeling bad on the other side
that's exactly right i love that i love
your terminology of a vicious asymmetry
and you know when we think about why on
earth would mother nature do that to us
it seems so cruel but if you think about
it from the perspective of millions of
years of evolution and that for most of
humanity we've lived in this very
dangerous world with very limited
resources and we've had to work very
hard to get those resources in order to
survive it makes perfect sense right if
you have a pleasure pain balance which
with a single exposure will give you
just a little bit of pleasure but then
afterwards we'll give you pain then
you're going to be very motivated to
keep going and find that next oasis or
find that next berry bush
we you know it's what has turned us into
these constant seekers never happy with
what we have always wanting more
except that our ability to be constant
seekers and always improve on our lives
and on our circumstance has essentially
allowed us to transform the world this
is really you know we're living in the
anthropocene in the sense that this is
the first time in human history that we
have used our brains and our technology
to create more abundance than we could
ever need or ever want
and not just abundance these highly
addictive highly reinforcing feel-good
drugs and behaviors essentially making
us all vulnerable to addiction because
our primitive wiring wasn't adapted for
the modern ecosystem have you heard the
quote after copulation the devil's
laughter can be heard
i haven't but that's good because a lot
of men report uh how would you say
acute post-coital depression um is
something after guys have sex sometimes
you feel a bit existentially once you've
finished up i can't remember it someone
like far too important and impressive
like young young said after after
copulation the devil's laughter can be
heard it sounds so apocalyptic but that
was something that i thought that was
interesting why after something that's
so enjoyable does something occur
afterward that is a bit unenjoyable and
it's because if you only ever had sex
once then you probably wouldn't have
very many grandkids and we are grand
children optimizing machines so the sex
just being a little bit more
uncomfortable or dissatisfying than you
thought that meal just being a little
bit more unfulfilling than you'd
anticipated those things
they make you want to go again
yes although let's tease this apart a
little bit because i think there might
be i would wonder when that qu when that
quote was said because it does get to
the issue of sex addiction and
pornography and kind of a nice segue
which i think is important to talk about
because i think it's a huge and growing
problem and we don't talk about it
enough so as long as you're comfortable
going there um
take me there
okay all right
so i mean you know when we have an
orgasm it releases a huge amount of
neurotransmitters in our brain including
dopamine it is in and of itself
a a chemical reinforcement um you know
whether we're having sex with another
person or sex with ourselves the orgasm
is reinforcing
and we do develop tolerance to that
reinforcing effect so if we repeatedly
have orgasms over a shorter period of
time they will be less reinforcing with
each subsequent orgasm and there's of
course this natural refractory period
too where it becomes even impossible to
have an orgasm
um if we're condensing so many orgasms
in a short amount of time so orgasms can
very much work like a drug and i think
um you know in the modern world where
sex is almost the last bastion of
physical things that we still do where
we are in our bodies and connecting with
our bodies
it has become become a really vulnerable
place for sex addiction
um so when i think about you know the
devil's laughter after after orgasm or
intercourse um especially and you you
say for men but i guess this could
include women
i think where that's probably amplified
is when sex is just an end in itself and
it's not um you know an expression of
intimacy and love between loving
partners but it's really um a way to get
an orgasm
and and i think you know when sex
becomes that and and only purely that
especially in large quantities
then it really becomes um all about the
dopamine and it becomes about that
release um divorced from
other meaning
and then of course we're going to go
into that dopamine deficit state and
it's going to be even more so
um than if we were
let's say having sex less frequently
and only
in a way that's kind of sacred or
sanctified so maybe that's a little bit
too holier than thou but those are sort
of my thoughts on it i'd be curious to
hear your thoughts
what i think is interesting is when
we've got two elements going on here you
have the experience and the subsequent
physiological impact
and the experience the phenomenological
experience of of that impact
but after that event you have the
retrospective
psychological way that you label the
experience overall that's the thing that
i think is really really interesting
what does it mean
to think back on a situation that you
had
and to frame that in a different way to
feel shame or guilt or envy or
dissatisfaction and
this interpretation how how does this
how does that slot in
yeah i mean i think that that's that's
exactly right that that's that's what
i'm trying to get out but you said it
even better um i mean
the meaning that we give to
that sexual act has a huge impact on how
we feel about it how we feel about
ourselves
um
you know sex itself i mean as you go
through life the more orgasms you have
it really is like a drug you just we
inevitably build up tolerance we need
more and more potent forms to get the
same effect
you know the the classic trajectory of
my sex addicted patients is that they
might start out masturbating to sort of
you know vanilla college girl
pornography and then 10 years later you
know it's it's something much more
deviant than that some sadomasochistic
thing and it's not really because
they're they're violent people or they
have a preference for that inalie it's
that they need some nothing more to you
know jazz it up because they become
tolerant
and you know
and that's and we're living longer now
you know than we ever did before like
when we died at 30 it was like well you
only had a limited amount of time to get
enough sex in there and now why why is
it that everyone isn't addicted to sex
then if that's the case if over time the
more orgasms that you have the more that
you need to be able to get the same
level of pleasure from them surely that
just puts everybody on a path to sex
edition but not everyone has that
no not everyone has that because part of
what makes somebody addicted is how hard
they're willing to work for their drug
so my neuroscience colleague rob malenka
he once summarized that beautifully he
does a bunch of animal studies and he
said yeah you know basically i can
measure how addicted a rat is by how
how hard it's willing to work to get
cocaine how many times it's willing to
press that lever you know to get a
little squoosh of cocaine and that's
really what separates people who become
addicted to a given drug from those who
don't at some point
most of us kind of tire out they say you
know what it's not worth it like chasing
that all around i'm done oh so does it
work there's a cost benefit analysis
that's going on along with the pleasure
pain dynamics yes yes yes
yes and and those people who are like
relentlessly trying to oppose those
neuro-adaptation gremlins and bring that
balance not just level but tweak it down
to the side of pleasure and they'll just
keep at it until they can do that those
are the people who become addicted plus
don't forget there's inter-individual
variability and drug of choice so what
works for one person is not going to
work for another person i mean as i talk
about in the book i got addicted to
romance novels i started with the
twilight saga
and i eventually you know over time
graduated to socially sanctioned
pornography for women which is these
erotica novels not consistent with my
values really embarrassing to talk about
but you know i didn't really see it as
it was happening i sort of only once i
sort of got to you know fifty shades of
gray at two in the morning i was like
why am i reading this you know and then
i stopped and i went through withdrawal
and it was really hard for me to stop
that i could really see that i had
become addicted but interestingly i've
never been tempted by alcohol it makes
me tired and gives me a headache
caffeine i would love if caffeine woke
me up it doesn't do a thing for me so
you've got to take into account that
we've got these different types of drugs
that work slight and on a population
level totally makes sense right you
would want on like a your tribe you
would want one guy to be out there you
know chasing raspberries and you would
want someone else looking for meat and
somebody else rounding up you know
i don't know so
we have a small amount of variability in
what are the the things that get us
going what are the addictions the small
sorts of addictions that we have and
that's adaptive
at a group level
because it spreads the pursuits
so that you um have a hedge one person's
getting fruit one person's getting
vegetable one person's having sex all
day yeah
i think so i mean i think so you know
that makes a lot of sense i have a i
have a confession to make with regards
to the dark romance stuff i'm on the
cover of about 15 dark romance novels so
oh my goodness you depending on what
what era it was you may have read a book
that's got my face on it um i probably
have i which would be many of them which
would be a first which is super
embarrassing
look we're all friends here anna all
right so what what else is it what about
serotonin is there a role for serotonin
to play are there any other chemicals
that we need to understand to kind of
give us a full picture
yeah so serotonin's really interesting
um i think you know it's it's really
associated with feeling connected to
other people that feeling of belonging
being part of the tribe if you look at
drugs like lsd basically what they do is
they cause a huge surge of serotonin um
you know in these limbic structures in
the brain and people will often report
this kind of
um connectivity um forgetting the self
um feeling you know this peace and and
this closeness which is of course a
really um wonderful
wonderful feeling so again you know all
these drugs work in a slightly different
way norepinephrine also a very potent
monoamine neurotransmitter which is
really important not just to enhance
mood but also for paying attention so
stimulants um often work on this
norepinephrine um pathways on
norepinephrine and they get our frontal
lobe really really focused and we get
really good at sort of automatic kinds
of rote tasks so all of these chemicals
are involved but interestingly the final
common pathway for all addictive
substances and behaviors is dopamine um
and you know
that that it's essentially the currency
that neuroscientists use to kind of
measure the addictive potential of
something is dopamine detoxing legit
then
you know i think so i i was doing it in
my practice long before it became
popular in social media i've been
practicing psychiatry for 25 years
and
it was something that i just sort of
happened along early on i would have
patients come in
primarily seeking help for depression
and anxiety and early on i would
prescribe them antidepressant or do
psychotherapy many of them who were also
actively using drugs and alcohol didn't
really get much better
then what i discovered and this is also
informed by the neuroscience because the
some studies show this too
that if instead of trying to initially
target their depression and anxiety i
got them to stop their drug of choice
what happened was and i asked them to do
that for 30 days so a 30-day abstinence
trial
in the first 14 days they felt much
worse because they were experiencing the
universal symptoms of withdrawal but by
30 days they really almost universally
enjoyed endorsed feeling better than
they had in a really long time less
anxious less depressed better able to
sleep and when you look at that from the
perspective of the neuroscience of
addiction it really makes sense because
essentially what's happening
is that the substance itself is driving
the depression and anxiety
that huge release of dopamine the reward
pathway is invariably followed by a
decrease in dopamine transmission below
baseline that dopamine deficit state
which is experienced as anxiety and
depression then we reach for our drug
again because we're feeling bad and
temporarily it feels like it alleviates
that so it's like oh this is making me
feel better i should keep doing this but
in fact the drug itself is what is
driving that dopamine deficit state that
makes us anxious and depressed in the
first place so the intervention is to
stop using the drug allow your own
dopamine transmission
and other feel-good hormones to up
regulate and then if you go back to
using your drug of choice make sure that
you use it in moderation
and that you don't press too hard on
that pleasure side of the balance so
that you don't end up in that dopamine
deficit state what else should people do
let's say that someone wants to do a
good dopamine detox other than
abstaining from whatever the behavior or
the drug is that they're
currently addicted to what else do you
advise them to do during that period
well you have to also be aware of
triggers um and also eliminate those
triggers so if you're somebody who's
addicted to video games like a patient
of mine and you find that once you go on
youtube and you start watching other
people play video games you're more
likely to play a video game yourself
then you should probably eliminate
youtube for that month if you're
somebody who's trying to quit smoking
cigarettes and you find if you have a
casual drink with friends you really
want to smoke a cigarette you should
probably eliminate alcohol for that
month as well and from the perspective
of neuroscience it makes a lot of sense
because we don't just get a release of
dopamine with our drug of choice we also
get a release of dopamine with any
reminder of our drug of choice so for
example my patient addicted to video
games when he watches other people play
video games that actually releases a
little bit of dopamine in his reward
pathway and he feels he feels a dopamine
surge but right after that it goes into
a dopamine deficit state he feels
craving and that craving is the
physiologic drive that sends him to want
to go and play the video game which is
why you know alcohol anonymous often
talks about avoiding people places and
things in that time when you're trying
to avoid the drug as well what's
happening in the brain when we get a cue
and a craving what's going on
so when we get a cue
for our drug of choice that is a
any kind of reminder of the drug like an
alert on our phone that someone texted
us
we get
dopamine released in our reward pathway
so that in itself is rewarding but that
reward is followed by a dopamine deficit
state and that don't mean deficit state
remember that is craving that is what
makes us then want to go out and get the
drug it's the deficit that drives the
motivation which is why people often
talk about dopamine is not really being
just about pleasure it's also about
motivation because it's that dopamine
deficit state and that balance to the
pain side that is an incredibly powerful
physiologic drive that gets us to do the
work to get our drug
um
what does social media and technology do
to our dopamine levels have you looked
at this
yeah so social media is essentially has
drug-ified human connection
we are
evolved over millions of years to want
to connect with other people we are
tribal creatures we're social animals um
my colleague rob malenca recently showed
that oxytocin the love hormone when it's
released binds to dopamine neurons in
the reward pathway and causes a release
of dopamine it's not really a surprise
to most of us we are motivated to
connect and our our brain gets us to do
that by releasing dopamine so it feels
good to connect that means that all of
those meta experiences that tell us
we're making a connection also release
dopamine so we we have a dopamine
release when people like us we have a
dopamine release when people agree with
us we have a doping release when people
um you know enhance our reputation
we have a dopamine release when we're
experiencing the same emotion at the
same time as other people so that's very
powerful which is why social media can
really be like this frenzy because when
we are getting outraged at the same time
as somebody else that releases dopamine
when we're laughing at the same time as
somebody else that releases dopamine
when we watch somebody watching a video
and we have the same reaction as they
have to that video that releases
dopamine which explains the mystery of
why we would ever want to watch people
watching other people but it makes
perfect intuitive sense reaction videos
explained yeah exactly yeah right but
what social media has unfortunately the
potential to do is actually drug-ify
human connection by contributing to all
of the features that make something
addictive and that is access quantity
potency and novelty so if we have easy
access to our drug of choice which we do
with social media
then we're more likely to get addicted
especially when you compare that to
prior to social media what you had to do
to go out and meet people right first of
all you had to get off the couch you had
to go out and find the people most of
them are going to be average looking and
average interesting right it's not like
that now
you know you can just stay on your couch
and swipe right or swipe left swipe left
quantity right so if you think about
almost all traditional drugs and alcohol
i mean typically eventually you run out
you got to go out and get more tick-tock
never runs out
if you look at potency
how do we make things more potency we
combine we potent we combine two drugs
together and that's exactly what social
media has done it's combined beautiful
images with sex with gaming
with gambling
with music with flashing lights to make
it all the more potent
and then finally novelty dopamine is
very
sensitive to anything that's new
especially if it's something that we
liked before but it's a slight variation
on that and these ai algorithms are
basically
learning us figuring out what we like
before and then suggesting something
that's similar but slightly different
which automatically triggers dopamine
automatically triggers our search and
explore function our treasure hunting
function you know when we're off and
running looking for that next slightly
better thing and then finally uh social
media has enumerated things it's given
it numbers and for reasons we don't
fully understand when we enumerate
things or when we have rankings or
number of likes that's really
reinforcing we tend to like that
why is it that some people find certain
things rewarding uh in terms of how we
interpret them so for instance one
person might really get ged up by
gaining followers on instagram but
another one might be really interested
in shooting people in a video game and
another one might be funny cat videos is
this more of that genetic spread from
the group do you think or is there
something else going on
i think it's mostly um just natural drug
of choice you know that some people are
just going to enjoy certain drugs and
not others and that there's variation in
the human population but some of it too
has to do with our social networks so
addiction really does spread like a
virus and we're more likely to try and
use drugs that people in our social
network are trying and using so if you
hang up
hang out with a bunch of video gamers
you're more likely to get online
partially because it's you know socially
enhancing it and binds you to them which
is you know also important for people
are behavioral interventions the only
solution then that dopamine detox and
you spend time away from your drug or
your activity of choice is it just down
to behavioral interventions or is there
a pharmacological solution for this can
we can we pray the addiction away what's
going on
yeah so addiction really is the
quintessential biopsychosocial disease
which means that we need biological
interventions psychological
interventions and social interventions
behavioral interventions
kind you know like like a dopamine fast
sort of cross all of those because
biologically what we're doing is
allowing reward pathways to reset
themselves allowing ourselves to look
back and see true cause and effect but
also in order to accomplish that um we
often have to change our environment or
change the people that we hang out with
so it's also psychological and social
but the that's not the only intervention
we can also use
chemicals to help people stop using so
for example naltrexone is an opioid
receptor blocker which can be used to
treat people not just with opioid
addiction but also with alcohol
addiction alcohol is mediated in part
through our endogenous opioid system so
by blocking our opioid receptors we make
the alcohol less reinforcing which means
people can use it not just to help them
stop drinking all altogether but
actually to reduce the amount that
they're drinking and that's a really
nifty tool because a lot of people don't
want to stop altogether they want to use
in moderation and when they use
naltrexone what they say is that i i'm
just better able to stop at two or three
drinks rather than progressing to six or
seven drinks i also just want to jump in
and emphasize that addiction really is a
spectrum disorder mild moderate and
severe and this dopamine fast
intervention is only really going to
work for folks who are sort of on the
borderline between being addicted and
being a little addicted or maybe a mild
to moderate addiction in terms of
just asking people to do it on their own
for people who are more severely
addicted the dopamine fast is equally
important but they probably won't be
able to do it entirely on their own they
may have to go into a rehab residential
treatment center or they may have to be
given you know um medications like an
opioid receptor blocker in order to even
make it possible for them to abstain so
i i just really want to emphasize that
we're talking about a spectrum disorder
and my book is mainly targeting people
who are a little bit addicted um
although the the ideas in there apply
really to addiction more broadly as well
is there a certain type of person who's
more likely to become addicted or more
likely to have multiple addictions
across multiple domains
yeah so our innate vulnerability to
addiction varies and some people are
definitely more vulnerable than others
about 50 percent of the risk of getting
addicted is biological or inherited so
there are studies showing that if you
have a biological parent or grandparent
with addiction you are at increased risk
compared to the general population of
becoming addicted yourself even if
raised outside of that substance using
home so there are really
interesting adoption studies showing
that when people with a biological
parent with addiction are raised in a
non-substance using home they are
increased risk of developing an
addiction themselves do you know if that
crosses domains do you know if someone
who has an alcoholic father is more
likely to be a gaming addicted son
that's very interesting i don't think we
have data on that these data are mainly
looking at alcohol use disorder in
fathers and sons
but that would be great to look into
what we speculate though is that this is
a general vulnerability to addiction uh
rather than a specific um
you know vulnerability to only one
substance and we know that because many
times when people will get in recovery
from one addiction one of the dangers is
cross addiction that they'll go on to
become addicted to something else
hmm what about psychological life events
so we've got 50 of this is heritable
because behavioral genetics is just this
emerging immutable bastard of a field
that keeps on telling everyone that
perhaps the freedoms you used to think
that you have they're not
they're not quite as free as they were
what about psychological life events
stuff that happens in early childhood
are the things that predispose us to
addictions
yeah so there are certain types of
mental illnesses that make people more
vulnerable to addiction separate from
the illness of addiction itself um you
know people with bipolar disorder are
more likely to get addicted or any kind
of intense emotion dysregulation certain
types of anxiety disorders um attention
deficit disorders is uh correlated uh
with increased risk of addiction
but not just innate mental illnesses
also um you know life early life
experiences like early life trauma
and epigenetics can contribute to
addiction risk we know that people who
experience significant trauma in early
life are at increased risk to go to go
on and develop addiction but also other
environmental factors like living in
poverty increases the risk of becoming
addicted unemployment increases the risk
of becoming addicted and then very
importantly
access is really important so if if you
live in a neighborhood or a region of
the country or a society where
addictive substances and behaviors are
more readily available you are more
likely to get addicted and i think
that's one of the most important risk
factors today but it's not it's seldom
appreciated well it's that robert ploman
argument where he talks about you can
have all of the genes for alcoholism but
if you're raised on a desert island that
doesn't have any alcohol it doesn't come
to fruition you can have a hundred
percent likelihood of being an alcoholic
but if you're not raised around any
alcohol
it's not happening so yeah exactly yeah
and the converse is true too you can
have very little risk for
becoming addicted to alcohol and yet if
you're constantly surrounded by it 24 7
and tempted and encouraged to use it and
you use enough of it it can change your
brain and you can become addicted to
alcohol so so i think that that's right
it's this interesting
stress vulnerability diathesis which is
true for most mental illnesses so
whether it's you know anorexia nervosa
or psychosis or addiction it's this
interplay between our innate god-given
vulnerability uh and the environment
that we live in
what's
what are some of the other risk factors
then
the loneliness uh you mentioned poverty
is one of them do does having a family
or having a dog does that make you less
likely to be addicted have you looked at
these
yeah yeah so um in general people who
have um
intimate supportive human connections in
their lives um are at decreased risk for
becoming addicted
people who have meaningful work
and are gainfully employed are at
decreased risk of becoming addicted
people who actively participate in
religious organizations are at decreased
risk of becoming addicted but again
remember these are
large epidemiologic studies so these are
from a population level on an individual
level nobody is immune you can have the
best family and the best job and be
the most spiritual person on the planet
and you can still get addicted what's
happening with the dopamine levels to do
with religion and
family and connection and jobs and stuff
what's happening with the dopamine
that's permitting those people to be
less susceptible
well probably what's happening is that
they're they're getting their dopamine
in more adaptive ways right i mean um
one of the things i talk about in the
book is what are some healthy and
adaptive sources of dopamine and
certainly intimate supportive human
connections is a really
essential and important and healthy
source of dopamine
but also meaning and purpose in life you
know having work that you believe in and
that keeps you busy and that you you
feel like is
valuable for the world that's very
important to giving people
um you know making them less likely for
them to get addicted
general psychological resilience really
helps and that's typically fostered by
other wellness practices like for
example exercising
and making sure that you're physically
healthy getting enough sleep
there's a great acronym in alcoholics
anonymous called
halt it stands for hungry angry lonely
and tired and it's just a nice way to
warn people that when you're hungry
angry lonely and tired you're at risk of
using your drug so try to beware and
take care of those things before you get
to that point that's amazing
i'm trying to work out you mentioned
about meaning and purpose there and some
of the
more
ephemeral
difficult to define
longer term life goals some of these are
quite conservative views things to do
with family connections and so on and so
forth
a lot of the time what people are trying
to chase
whether it be through internet use or
drug use or finding a new game or
getting themselves into a community of
some kind or whatever it is
they're trying to chase some sense of
pleasure and if dopamine is the primary
key
pleasure giving
hormone that we have in our brain
hormone chemical
yeah chemical neurotransmitter
neurotransmitter yep uh i knew that
if that's if that's the case
starting
afresh trying to really step back from
the urgent day-to-day things that you're
doing with your life and actually trying
to connect to a deeper sense of purpose
that must be one of the most robust ways
that you can actually ensure that you
have a scalable
continuous sense of pleasure throughout
the remainder of your life to try and
find and really really genuinely deeply
connect with the things that you are
doing and it seems like
what we have in a hyper-convenient world
is
a very
shiny object that sits over the top like
a shiny glaze that people continue going
back to that doesn't allow us to get to
the much more replicable uh and
consistent deeper meaning that you get
underneath is that right
yeah i mean i would agree with that i i
you know i
the pursuit of pleasure for its own sake
ultimately leads to anhedonia or the
absence of pleasure in anything that we
do
and so
on some level pursuing pleasure is a
mistake
i mean we're constantly being told that
we should pursue pleasure and that
there's pleasure out there waiting for
us and that if we're not happy or you
know ecstatic then something's wrong
with us we need to get new friends or a
new job or a new spouse but the truth is
that that again just this relentless
pursuit of pleasure actually makes us
miserable
and what we need to do is stop looking
for it stop looking for that dopamine
hit and essentially
try to find a way of being in the world
that isn't
primarily focused
on rewards but instead um you know
fosters a different meaning and purpose
um
for being and you you know you hit on it
exactly i mean people can get this in
different ways but
you know finding a sense of of
purpose in the world or you know a
reason for living typically this is
living for others
um that can really
make us feel like it's all worth it
without necessarily making us feel
that we're experiencing pleasure but but
really almost more that we can endure
the pain of being alive because being
alive is actually pretty painful
and that it's worth it it's worth
sticking around for
um because you know we want to be here
to accomplish some some greater goal or
we have we believe that we have uh some
meaning and purpose in life so i do i do
really think that that's really
important and that we need
to shift our whole frame around um you
know this
mirage really of the pursuit of pleasure
unfortunately it is the natural
byproduct and and the dark side of
capitalism you know a successfully
capitalist society will ultimately tell
us that the highest good
is to consume and uh that the more we
consume and the better the stuff that we
get um the happier we'll be and of
course that's it's not true is dopamine
related to the hedonic treadmill then oh
absolutely i mean it's fundamentally
related right because
if we just this relentless pursuit of
dopamine hits ultimately drives down our
own endogenous production of dopamine
and we end up
less happy than where we started whereas
the pursuit of pain and i use that that
term very broadly to me not just
physical pain although i include that
too but also just doing things that are
hard and inconvenient and require
effortful engagement those are the
things that lightly press on our pain
side and ultimately cause our own
endogenous re-regulating mechanisms to
upregulate dopamine and norepinephrine
and serotonin all those feel-good
hormones but not with the initial
stimulus they're the delayed reward as
the compensatory or healing mechanism
for the initially painful stimulus the
brain's managed to turn everything into
a drug hasn't it the the end result the
net end result of everything is
neurotransmitters and different levels
so whether that be buying the 200 000
pounds car and then thinking oh well
that one hasn't quite got but the 250
000 pounds car that's right and it'll be
once i get the new lights in the
driveway and then when i upgrade the
house and when i do and that is just the
dopamine system playing out in real life
but when people talk about the fact that
keeping up with the joneses what is that
it's the dopamine system existing in the
real world manifesting in people's
purchasing
behaviors yes exactly i mean you're
exactly right we created this world and
it's sort of the the natural
end point of our pleasure pain balance
because we're constantly we're wired to
constantly seek out pleasure and and
avoid pain but i'm i'm hopeful that it's
not the end of us although the data
would suggest it just might be 70
percent of global deaths are
attributable to modifiable risk factors
that is to say smoking diet and lack of
exercise
so if we don't rapidly turn around the
way that we're constantly consuming um
then you know we're probably going to go
extinct we're going to sort of titillate
ourselves to death but i i humans are
kind of amazing in their adaptability
and i am optimistic that you know with
these kinds of conversations um we're
gonna say okay wait a minute we need to
change something here um what's a new
way to orient on this as you say hyper
convenient world
let's talk about the other side of the
seesaw then how can people utilize pain
effectively or discomfort to make their
lives better
there's a whole science of hormesis and
hormesis is greek for to set in motion
and the idea of hormesis is that by
exposing ourselves to
mild toxic or noxious stimuli we can
actually
become stronger and heal and the way
that works is that
when we expose ourselves to noxious
stimuli and examples would be extreme
temperatures
starvation
exercise exercises and noxious stimulus
at the cellular level what that does is
that sets in motion our body's own
healing mechanisms and it tells our body
oh boy there's an injury here you need
to upregulate dopamine serotonin
norepinephrine all those feel good
hormones
and so hormesis is actually a way to
press on the pain side of the balance in
order to get the gremlins to hop on the
pleasure side to reset the the hedonic
set point to the side of pleasure and it
really does work and i think it is the
necessary modus operandum for this
dopamine overloaded world we have to
intentionally
and willfully invite pain into our lives
and and that means we need to do things
like exercise take cold water baths
you know do things that are effortful
and hard expose ourselves to things that
makes us make us anxious and we have to
do it on purpose and we have to do it on
a regular daily basis in order to keep
our hedonic set point to the side of joy
what are some of the discomfort
uh pathways that people might not
realize are so it's something like
trying to learn a new language or trying
to write an article or trying to learn
something
are these the same are there any others
yeah anything that requires a kind of
sustained concentration and by the way
that that's getting harder and harder
because we're constantly interrupting
ourselves with intrusive thoughts of
wanting to check our devices so putting
all the devices away turning off all the
alerts and just allowing ourselves to
try in the moment to focus
and to notice when we're interrupting
ourselves but to not let ourselves be
distracted with something else and to
try to stay in that moment write it out
and then continue to concentrate um
that's a simple example you know to do
something creative or to read something
that's kind of difficult
or learn something new learn a language
those are all learning is a great great
example
um other things can be things that are
just boring right i mean we're so we've
sort of lost the ability to be bored
we're so constantly entertained you know
whether it's music pumping in one
direction or what have you so just kind
of letting ourselves um you know in some
some ways some people call it meditation
or breathing or just going for a walk
without headphones in
allowing ourselves to be bored anxious
paying attention to the constant
ruminations of our own brain which are
mostly boring and annoying and negative
um
but you know instead of trying to just
drown them out just saying oh okay i'll
be let's be curious about that and try
to learn something about ourselves and
the world
try to focus um
on the world so i think we do so much
trying to escape into a fantasy world
and pay less and less attention to our
immediate environments but just try to
like pay attention to the environment
and tolerate the distress of being in
the moment one of the things i i think
is important to emphasize is
you know there's this this kind of
language like be here now and be in the
moment
and when i was in college i kept trying
to do that and thought i was doing it
wrong
because every time i would do that i was
like uh i i hate this feeling you know
being here in the moments it's miserable
it's boring it's it's awful
and i thought i was doing it wrong
somehow compared to other people because
i thought well if i could just get this
right i would feel good but what i
finally realized is no being in the
moment is it's hard it is all those
awful things including being bored and
being anxious and that's kind of the
point that letting ourselves be here now
and tolerate the distress of being alive
is something that we need to do on
purpose what's happening in the brain we
spoke about smartphone addiction what
happens when we have that desire to
check our phone let's say that the
notification hasn't gone off but we have
a compulsion what is that is that
myelination is that just that we have a
bunch of very well
um
rehearsed
pathways in our brain that wants us to
do it or is there something else is
there an imbalance what's going on
i think basically what's happened is you
know we've gotten into the euphoric
recall loop so people with severe
addiction will often talk about euphoric
recall have their own memory of using
itself becomes a trigger that then
triggers cravings and drives use and
that can happen with all of us like for
example with the phone where suddenly
you know we have and part of craving is
by the way intrusive thoughts so it's
not like we intentionally have the
thought the thought just barges in on
our current thought process and we can
have that all the time with our phone
like oh uh you know i wonder
so this is my we don't have alerts so we
just oh i wonder i wonder who emailed me
i wonder you know i wonder who texted me
and then that's essentially euphoric
recall
and that drives dopamine up followed by
dopamine deficit followed by craving and
then we're really in physiologic
withdrawal and we feel like this feeling
can only be resolved by my checking my
phone and indeed we check the phone and
it does temporarily resolve the feeling
because now we get a bigger hit of
dopamine and we've you know restored
homeostasis but right afterwards it's
going to drive it down even further
which it sets up these loops so euphoric
recall
is like a
self-perpetuated
self-created cue
yes exactly
[ __ ] the human brain is so great and
then there's some things and you're like
why is that there who put that in there
that's such a stupid feature
yes i know that's so true but again i
just look at it from an evolutionary
perspective like if you you know were
sitting around you know and you eating
all the berries and like and you just
could chill out there for like a week
that would not be good right you would
you would probably starve to death
because but you wouldn't have gotten up
and and put enough effort into finding
the next berry bush or whatever running
away from the lion so i just think it's
you know it's how we evolve for a world
of scarcity but as you say it's really
messed up for our current ecosystem
what would you give people as advice
overall to keep
dopamine
under control let's say that someone
doesn't have a
outstanding
use addiction maybe sometimes they spend
too much time on the phone maybe
sometimes when they're on a night out
they struggle to not go from five drinks
to ten but just a very sort of standard
user of dopamine what are some of the
ways that people can or the habits that
people can take away that they can
instantiate into their daily life
yeah well i do recommend starting out
with a dopamine fast in order to restore
um homeosta static baselines and if you
can't do a month can you do two weeks
you know in my experience to really
reset reward pathways it does take a
month of not using our drug of choice
but if you can't spare that do a couple
weeks if you can't even do that just do
a single day and notice in that day how
you will go through
experiences of craving intrusive
thoughts euphoric recall triggers
how hard it is how you'll be restless
anxious i think just becoming mindfully
aware of that process is is a good and
helpful first step then when we go back
to using keep in mind the balance and
the gremlins and try to use in
moderation so that you don't get into
this vicious cycle of too many gremlins
hopping on the pain side of the balance
so that you're in this dopamine deficit
state where you're basically net
negative and you have to keep using just
to feel normal and ways to do that are
to
engage in pleasurable activities that
are not too potent and to do it not too
often so that you leave enough space in
between for the gremlins to hop off and
for homeostasis to be restored certainly
once we're into daily use um it's much
harder to keep our balance
in check and i would also add that um a
lot of times people will be like well i
only use cannabis once a week but i and
i only use alcohol once a week and i
only use poppers once a week but at the
end of the week they've used something
every day so you also want to be mindful
of that and what we're really talking
about is that you want to have two or
three days ever at least every week
where you're not using any kind of
potent
rewarding behavior and again that's all
to leave enough time for homeostasis to
be restored
um and then you want to put you know
self-binding strategies in place these
can be physical or metacognitive that's
things like not keeping your drug easily
accessible in your home or you know
putting your phone on grayscale these
are all things people have talked about
to make it less potent or deleting
certain apps
or keeping a careful record anything
that kind of keeps you accountable but
also puts a little bit of a pause
between more friction
yeah a little bit more friction exactly
between you and your drug of choice and
then a metacognitive strategy that i
find is really useful is telling the
truth
if we force ourselves to tell the truth
about what we're doing where we've been
what we've consumed to other humans
we're much more likely to be truthful
with ourselves and also there is
evidence that telling the truth which is
an active and engaging and difficult
thing to do probably up regulates or
potentially upregulates the prefrontal
cortex that big gray matter area behind
behind our foreheads and the prefrontal
cortex is really important for helping
us regulate our pleasure pain balance so
telling the truth about things large and
small what i call radical honesty is
really really important for being able
to delay gratification and also hold
ourselves accountable not just to our
past selves but also our future selves
is that why vulnerability and opening up
to people can sometimes inherently feel
pleasurable
yeah so as i said before deep human
connections are a really healthy and
adaptive source of dopamine and one of
the way to one of the ways to create
intimacy is to be honest with people
especially when it's hard to do
especially when we're telling them
something about ourselves which casts
ourselves in a somewhat negative light
or makes us look you know not as awesome
as maybe we would like to look in their
eyes
and we always think that when we when we
when we do that that will like people
will run away from us but in fact the
opposite happens people experience a
shared a sense of brokenness and a
shared sense of vulnerability and
actually feel closer to us let's say
that someone's had a behavioral
addiction it could have involved a
substance or it might not have done it
could have been phone use or smoking and
they've engaged in this behavior
consistently for a long period of time
and then they
stopped do those neural pathways ever
disappear do they ever
atrophy or are they always there are we
always going to have an increased level
of susceptibility the reason i ask this
is i once heard a story about a young
girl who used to go horse riding and
when she turned 14 or 15 she started
smoking when she was horse riding
because her parents weren't around and
they couldn't ever smell it on her
because she came back stinking a horse
is not smoke
and then 10 or 15 years later she had a
daughter and she wanted to take her
daughter horse riding she'd stop smoking
when she got pregnant she'd stop smoking
when she'd had the daughter took the
daughter horse riding again got on a
horse for the first time in 15 years
immediately wanted to have a cigarette
so
is it the case
that we need to be incredibly the the um
pathways that we lay down early in our
lives are with us for the rest of time
or can we actually get them to atrophy
and go away
so a little bit of both there's there is
evidence that once we become addicted to
a substance or behavior there's a latent
scar
of that addiction that will always be
there and will never go away and the
example that you gave is a is a really
good one and what often happens with
people with severe addiction is when
they're triggered
at or or exposed to the drug itself or
another drug that can plummet them not
just into moderate use but right back to
where they were in the deepest depths of
their addiction
there's also interesting animal studies
showing that if you take a rat and you
inject it over
seven successive days with cocaine what
you will find is that the rat will go
from hovering on the edges of the cage
to running around in the middle of the
cage and by the seventh day it's in a
running frenzy and that can be measured
by how often it breaks beams of light
that are across the cage now if you
take that cocaine away
for a whole lifetime for a whole year
which is essentially a rat lifetime and
then you expose that same and what will
happen is they'll stop running and
they'll start going back to their normal
behavior
um but then if a year later you expose
that rat to a single injection of
cocaine they'll immediately be back into
that running frenzy as if they were on
day seven
very strongly suggesting that there's
some fundamental brain change that
occurs that never goes away
on the other hand although the evidence
supports the idea that there are damaged
areas of the brain that never heal
there's also really interesting work
being done by my colleagues here at
stanford showing that recovery
is characterized by building new neural
neural pathways around these damaged
areas so recovery can happen it can be
it's robust people can get into recovery
and be in recovery their whole lives and
never relapse again and what's probably
happening is again they're building new
neural networks that reroute around
those damaged areas what i'm thinking
about is the common addiction that
pretty much everybody has which is
overuse of phones
and that
you really do
set the tone
for your later life with the actions
that you make in your earlier life
yes and if it's the case that every time
that you have
something in your pocket that you
automatically go to pick it up to take
it out you have your apps in the
position you can almost navigate with
your eyes closed yeah to go through
these sorts of things
the implications are like really really
grave and
it sounds like they're quite
it's we should pick up behaviors
with real trepidation
yes i agree with you it's why i strongly
advocate that children not have their
own devices until they're at least 12 or
13.
well just as as you say um you know
those are formative years the brain is
developing rapidly the coping strategies
that kids learn early in life will last
them a lifetime
and if we don't in that time teach them
healthy coping strategies if we don't
foster social networks with people in
real life if we don't
teach them about you know how to be well
with exercise and diet and spiritual
practices
and we just give them a phone um that's
that's gonna be very bad for their
ability to reverse those behaviors later
on
um
so i think it's essential that you know
kids be shielded from these devices for
as long as possible now once they become
teenagers they're just gonna go out and
get their own devices if you don't get
them on them but even then monitoring
their use um you know data show that
that parents who are actually um know
where their kids are and what their kids
are doing and what what kinds of
things they're doing online those kids
are less likely to develop
serious addictions to social media and
other things than than parents who are
super hands-off so it does require
you know careful monitoring and
discussion
um early in life so that people can be
mindful but having said that i will say
that i have seen people with very severe
addictions get into recovery in mid and
late life so it's really remarkable what
people can reverse in terms of these
incredibly addictive and reinforcing
behaviors when you know when they when
they
decide and when they have access to the
resources help them get into and
maintain recovery that's reassuring to
hear yeah it is a bunch of a bunch of
things floating around in my mind james
clear saying
first we make our habits and then our
habits make us that every action that
you take is a vote for the future sort
of person that you're going to become
and then there's a jordan petersonism
that says don't practice what you do not
want to become and that reminds us that
each of the little individual actions
are pushing us towards one particular
type of future or another and every time
you do it it's making doing it again
more likely tomorrow and the next day
and the next day
it's
it really is it doesn't surprise me that
your bucket the best sellers list
because it's such a
pervasive
ubiquitous problem that pretty much
every person that's living in the first
world now has what what does it mean to
be in a hyper-convenient world where we
can get whatever we want where
discomfort is something that we can
evade at the touch of a button where
boredom is something that we can
eliminate by getting anything out of our
pocket yeah it um that pleasure pain
balance has been skewed in a manner that
is
quite unhealthy
yeah i think that's right and then on
top of it all you know uh data show that
people are getting more depressed and
more anxious and the richer the nation
the more depressed and anxious we're
getting happiness surveys show that
people were uh less happy in 2018 than
they were in 2008 and then added to all
that unhappiness is the guilt for being
unhappy because we look around and say
why you know why on earth like i should
feel really good and yet i i don't i'm
unhappy and that's where i think
understanding the neuroscience of
pleasure and pain is super helpful
because it's just it makes us realize
that oh i get it i'm unhappy because i'm
constantly surrounded by pleasure and
that pleasure is my brain is wildly
trying to accommodate that fire hose of
dopamine and is making me miserable as a
result and there are actionable things
that we can do
to reverse that and that's what's so
exciting and we can insulate ourselves
from pleasure and we can intentionally
challenge ourselves and do things that
are hard
so crazy to hear we can insulate
ourselves from pleasure in the pursuit
of fulfillment and leading a better life
yeah i know it is paradoxical but it's
real it works anna lemke ladies and
gentlemen dopamine nation finding
balance in the age of indulgence will be
linked in the show notes below why
should people go if they want to find
out more of the stuff that you do
well let's see i'm not on social media
but um
on alemke.com has is sort of a website
that has other information and of course
these shows like yours are you know
great great opportunity to have great
conversations so thank you thank you
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
you